[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public votre
rendez-vous de débat de reportage et
d'analyse comme tous les soirs 18h 22h
sur Public Sénat vous le savez notre
objectif c'est de donner du sens à
l'actualité grâce à nos experts 90
minutes de débats avec l'actu pour
commencer et le Brésil fracturé après la
courte victoire de Lula les partisans de
bolsonaro bloquent les routes dans
certains états et appelle l'armée à
intervenir peut-on vivre un scénario à
l’américaine jusqu'à la passation de
pouvoir en janvier et Lula qui affirme
ceci
est de retour que
le Brésil est trop grand pour être
relégué à ce triste rôle de paria du
monde
Lula peut-il réparer son pays fracturé
que va-t-il se passer pour l'Amazonie ou
bien les accords commerciaux entre
l'Europe et le Brésil réponse dans une
minute et puis notre grand débat
volontairement décalé de l'actualité du
jour il portera sur la fatigue
informationnelle un Français sur deux se
dit saturé d'image de news d'alerte de
polémique en boucle on analysera ce
phénomène avec une sociologue une
journaliste et un historien pour
détailler ce constat inquiétant pour
notre démocratie et amorcée des
solutions afin de redonner goût aux
infos mais d'abord le point de la
situation Brésil entre publication des
résultats et blocage des routes Samia de
chia il refuse de s’avouer vaincu mais
petit à petit les barrages des partisans
de Jaïr bolsonaro sont levés seul huit
étaient du Brésil sont encore touchés
par des blocages routiers contre 21 au
pic de la mobilisation hier la police a
commencé à les déloger par la force et
surtout Jair bolsonaro a lui-même appelé
à la fin des blocages
débloquer les routes cela ne fait pas
partie mon sens de ces manifestations
légitimes ne perdons pas notre
légitimité ici d'autres manifestations
qui ont eu lieu dans tout le Brésil sur
les places font partie comme je le dis
du jeu démocratique
les manifestations légitimes aux yeux de
Jair bolsonaro ce sont celles des
dizaines de milliers de personnes
rassemblées hier devant les
commandements militaires de Rio de
Janeiro Sao Paulo ou encore Brasilia
persuadés que l'élection brésilienne de
dimanche est entacée d'irrégularité ces
manifestants en appellent à l'armée pour
organiser un nouveau scrutin nous ne le
reconnaissons pas parce que nous savons
qu'il est frauduleux comme tout ce que
fait le Parti des Travailleurs c'est
frauduleux
nous sommes ici devant le commandement
militaire de l'Est à demander de l'aide
aux généraux
le peuple fait ce qu'il peut nous sommes
à bout au secours général
a pourtant lui-même fini par reconnaître
sa défaite dimanche le président sortant
du Brésil est arrivé juste derrière son
adversaire Luna crédité de 50,9% des
voix à 77 ans l'ancien métallo demande à
présidentielle au compteur et un passage
par la caisse prison fait son grand
retour à la tête du Brésil mais cette
fois la tâche s'annonce bien plus
compliquée Lula a gagné la
présidentielle mais les bolsonaristes
sont majoritaires au Congrès et
l'opposition gouverne désormais 14 des
27 États du Brésil
et c'est donc une situation passionnante
à analyser à décortiquer avec mes
invités Armel Henders bonsoir bienvenue
vous êtes historienne spécialiste du
Brésil contemporain professeur à
l'Université Paris 8 Vincennes
Saint-Denis et auteur de l'histoire du
Brésil publié aux éditions
chandaigne j'accueille également Armelle
charrier bonsoir bienvenue à vous
éditorialiste international à la France
24 spécialistes en géopolitique
stratégie et défense Gaspa Estrada
bonsoir bienvenue directeur exécutif de
l'Observatoire politique de l'Amérique
latine et des Caraïbes à Sciences Po et
Laetitia cruppa éditoris politique
bonsoir Laetitia et bienvenue je
commence avec ce blocage des routes
peut-être ce qu'on sait de la situation
en cette fin d'après-midi on vient de
voir le sujet de Samia de chir ce
mouvement des routiers favorables à
bolsonaro armelenders et est-ce que le
président battu est à la manœuvre malgré
son appel à ne pas utiliser ce mode de
manifestation oui il était à la manœuvre
c'était à peu près vu même avant le
résultat des élections alors c'est pas
un mouvement général des camionneurs
c'est de certains camionneurs dans
certains États dans certains états très
belles sonorisé avec ce sont surtout les
certains patrons et quelques camionneurs
il faut bien le dire et puis avec la
complicité de la police des routes qui
est devenue une sorte de milice
personnelle pour molsonaru ok donc ça
c'est déjà assez éclairant sur la
situation du pays Armelle charrier il
faut peut-être expliquer un peu cette
période là intermédiaire
un peu comme aux États-Unis c'est
seulement début janvier que Lula sera
officiellement désigné comme président
est-ce que pour autant
jerbolsonaro peut mettre en place une
stratégie à la Trump puisqu'on est un
peu dans ce dans cette comparaison qu'on
ne peut pas s'empêcher de faire entre
les deux pays oui puisque il s'est dit à
un moment donné qu'il se voyait un peu
comme l'élève de Donald Trump donc on a
tendance à le regarder avec ce prisme là
alors si on le regarde vraiment en
calcan ce qui s'était passer aux
États-Unis on voit quand même quelques
différences parce que quand Donald Trump
avait été dans l'antre c'est entre deux
il n'avait pas pris la parole avec
autant de précisions que le fait
bolsonaro quand il prend la disparue il
dit quand même qu'il respecte la
Constitution il reconnaît le nombre
d'électeurs qui ont voté pour lui et il
n'y a pas ce flou qui avait gardé Donald
Trump qui était vraiment de dire les
élections elles ont été truquées je ne
reconnais pas les chiffres parce que je
dis que le vote par correspondance ou le
vote qui a été fait par avec des lettres
qui devaient arriver c'était trop
décalage on a bourré les urnes etc donc
il y avait vraiment cette idée que on a
eu volé la victoire et on se souvient
que derrière il y avait toute son
intelligancia républicaine qui le
lâchait au fur et à mesure parce qu'on
lui disait bon là il va falloir quand
même avancer un petit peu quand même il
va falloir reconnaître puis on voyait
des gouverneurs ou envoyer des cadres
des parties républicains qui à un moment
donné lui reconnaissait la victoire et
donc on n'a pas ce sentiment là je sais
pas le saunaro on a le sentiment
peut-être qu'il peut un peu plus fin sur
cette question là c'est à dire qu'il dit
moi grosso modo je vois que j'ai des
mouvements qui me sont favorables et
bien je vais en jouer est-ce que c'est
d'ailleurs c'est vous qui le serait
mieux que moi est-ce qu'il se positionne
comme ça en chef d'opposition est-ce que
il s'ouvre une manœuvre derrière
politique on ne le sait pas mais on voit
que ça lui coûte mais que quand même il
accepte un petit peu de lâcher la main
par rapport à Trump et on verra que dans
ces résultats il y a certes la victoire
de Lula relativement serré 50,9% mais il
y a aussi le Parlement avec le vote
début octobre et puis les gouverneurs on
y reviendra dans un instant mais je
voudrais avec vous gaspardestrada et
évoquer le la passation de pouvoir l'une
des infos de ce jeudi fin d'après-midi
c'est que il y a une rencontre qui se
prépare entre les équipes de Lula et
celle de bolsonaro c'est plus alors
c'est parce que sur quoi ça va débouché
mais c'est quand même plutôt bon signe
oui c'est ce qui est prévu d'ailleurs
par une loi qui a été votée en 2002 et
prévoit que l'équipe de transition aura
droit à 50 postes quand fonctionnaires
qui vont donc désigner par l'équipe
entente qui vont s'occuper justement de
faire le l'audit des actions
gouvernementales et de préparer les
premières missions du gouvernement qui
va être investi le 1er janvier cela il
me semble que c'est un signal
d'ouverture de la part des alliés de
bolsonaro et je voudrais juste rebondir
sur ce qui a été dit je pense que il y a
deux questions centrales aujourd'hui la
question 1 politique c'est à dire quelle
sera l'avenir de bolsonaro lorsque Lula
sera président il y a aussi un volet
judiciaire la famille de bolsonaro
bolsonaro lui-même et ses trois enfants
qui sont tous en politique
ont des affaires ont des mises en examen
et une des questions centrales de
l'avenir politique de walsonaro passera
par les tribunaux puisque désormais
bolsonaro pourra être jugé
et donc une des questions centrales pour
lui et pour sa famille c'est comment
faire en sorte de avoir une
infrastructure juridique lui permettra
de se défendre vis-à-vis de ses mises en
examen et donc aujourd'hui on l'a su par
la presse brésilienne le patron du Parti
libéral donc qui a
défendu qui a postulé bolsonaro de ce
scrutin lui a promis
une équipe d'avocats pour pouvoir le
défendre en échange d'une sorte de
reconnaissance certes implicite puisque
cela a été évoqué des élections et donc
ce qui est en train de faire aujourd'hui
une émotion de négociation aussi sur
l'avenir judiciaire de bolsonaros c'est
sur la décapité de vos choses à eux de
se défendre dans ses affaires qui vont
le suivre dans les mois à venir risque
de la prison
mais quand on dit négociation Armel
Anders c'est ça veut dire que Lula peut
négocier avec bolsonaro une transition
c'est une question de béotien une
transition apaiser au prix de d'une
défense
normalement
effectuée devant les tribunaux non parce
qu'il y a des tribunaux indépendants qui
font leur travail comment
négocier avec bolsonaro sa sortie alors
que les alliés de bolsonaro essaye de de
de
disons de le convaincre de de faire
profil bas au moins pour le moment c'est
c'est sans doute le cas enfin c'est sûr
que c'est une de ces parce que à partir
du 1er janvier il n'a plus de d'immunité
donc il y a beaucoup de choses qui qui
risquent de changer pour lui mais il y a
pas alors après politiquement c'est très
difficile parce que
ça sera exploité enfin il jouera les
martyrs de toute façon donc c'est mais
je pense que c'est franchement une
question relativement enfin c'est une
question importante pour le sonore
lui-même mais pas très importantes dans
le dans le cadre de la de la transition
ce qui par rapport à aux États-Unis
justement parce qu'il y avait je pense
que la Cour suprême et les l'ensemble
des forces politiques étaient bien
conscientes du modèle Trump le système
électoral n'est pas du tout le même le
système électoral brésilien c'est le
un des plus efficaces et les plus
sérieux du monde
le président du de la Cour suprême a
vraiment joué et qui était aussi garant
de la justice électorale a aussi joué
assez finement pour éviter ce que
cherchait les bolsonaristes un repas une
crise institutionnelle qui aurait
conduit au report des élections il a
évité ça il y a un consensus sur le fait
que ces élections se sont bien passées
après suffisamment important l'écart
auraient été plus grand que ça aurait
été pareil ça franchement je pense que
ça ne change rien peut-être que ça
aurait été plus contesté non vous pensez
pas je pense
de toute façon le problème
de défense et et je pense que ça ne
change rien pour le problème de ne pas
perdre les élections et de les perdre
face à Lula c'est ça doit être une
humiliation terrible pour lui donc donc
c'est vraiment ça la question une
réaction puisée dans l'une de ces
manifestations pro bolsonaro des
Brésiliens qui exigent une intervention
de l'armée on écoute l'un d'entre eux
nous demandons aujourd'hui tout comme
par le passé en 1964 d'activer l'article
142 qui est le code d'intervention
militaire pour que notre pays ne
devienne pas un pays communiste
que sait-on de l'engagement politique de
l'armée brésilienne est-ce que ce
manifestant peut-être entendu ne
serait-ce que par une partie de l'armée
l'armée elle a à ma connaissance quand
même un temps peu un soutien vis-à-vis
de bolsonaro c'est indéniable après elle
a pas la capacité je pense aujourd'hui
de se dire que elle va faire un coup
d'état parce que là on est on rentre
dans autre chose on rentre avec les
souvenirs d'un Brésil qui était sous
dictature militaire et on repart sur une
page d'histoire simplement c'est vrai
que ce qu'on voit c'est qu'il y a
toujours cette espèce de grand écart
dans ces pays effectivement de
l'Amérique du Sud qui est d'avoir soit
du communisme et donc c'est grande vague
qui ont été des vagues à un moment donné
de dire on s'ouvre au monde on est dans
le partage et on avance et puis il était
très proche effectivement des
soviétiques à l'époque et on en garde en
fait aujourd'hui quand on regarde le
Venezuela ou Cuba qui restait
effectivement c'est ces pays-là mais
soit effectivement tout de suite
du slogan de Donald Trump mec américain
great again et on sait aussi déjà que il
a repris son bâton de pèlerin Donald
Trump il est parti là en meeting il fait
toute une tournée pour les élections
demi-mandat qui arrive la semaine
prochaine le 8 novembre et on sait aussi
alors ça c'est vraiment un secret de
polichinelle qu'il a envie de d'y
retourner en 2024 il a envie de se
représenter ses proches le raconte même
à qui veut l'entendre que il n'arrive
pas à attendre l'année prochaine il
s'était fixé l'année prochaine pour
annoncer sa candidature et là il est
dans les starting box il veut y aller
est-ce que ça peut être le même schéma
la même stratégie pour jaillir bolsona
c'est très difficile à dire on peut pas
non plus faire une comparaison comme ça
des gars à égal mais c'est vrai que
quand on voit toutes les manifestations
de soutien avec leur slogan parce que je
vous ai écouté Armel tout à l'heure mais
on entend quand même dans les slogans
cette idée d'élection volée parce que
avant même que les élections aient lieu
gère bolsonaro a orchestré une campagne
de désinformation où il sous-entendait
que s'il perdait ses élections c'est ça
veut dire que c'était des élections
truquées donc vous voyez qu'il y a quand
même tout le bolsonarisme qui est encore
présent avec son corpus de
désinformation de propagande de ce qu'on
appelle et de ce que Donald Trump va
appeler la Poste vérité et même les
faits alternatifs pourtant là entendu
tout à l'heure dans le sujet d'ouverture
de notre débat il y a un appel au calme
de la part de du président battu oui oui
et c'était intéressant aussi ce que vous
disiez Armel parce que c'est vrai que on
l'entend on entend qu'il respecte la
Constitution mais si on zoome un peu
plus et c'est ce que j'ai fait dans le
discours on entend aussi à quelque chose
déjà on remarque que explicitement il ne
reconnaît pas sa défaite qu'il ne nomme
pas lu là et aussi qu'il utilise un
registre que les populistes adorent
l'émotion écoutait
dans tout le Brésil je sais que vous
êtes contrarié que vous êtes triste vous
vous attendiez à autre chose je suis
aussi bouleversé je suis aussi triste
que vous mais nous devons garder la tête
froide
voilà alors la tristesse c'est l'émotion
que
c'est assez malin finalement parce que
ça va à l'encontre de lubrise de Donald
Trump de la colère justement mais ça ne
veut rien dire et ça ne on peut pas
imaginer les actions qui va mettre
ensuite en place dans le futur le
bolsonarisme vous l'avez dit ça garde
des relais dans toutes les institutions
Lula va devoir composer avec et puis
personne ne sait si bolsonaro ne va pas
mettre en place via les réseaux sociaux
via par exemple les boucles WhatsApp qui
ont énormément fonctionné pendant toute
la campagne des nouvelles campagnes de
propagande à destination de l'opinion
publique c'est le grand danger de notre
époque où finalement la raison est
menacée et c'est la force aussi de tous
les populistes même perdus ils ont
encore le numérique comme outil et comme
arme fatale oui et puis on l'a évoqué et
on va maintenant rentrer dans le détail
il y a de vrais relais politiques il y a
eu des victoires politiques pour
bolsonaro dans ce dans ce scrutin
notamment ces candidats l'ont emporté
dans 14 États sur les 27 que que compte
que le Brésil a Confédération
brésilienne 14 gouverneurs probolesonaro
14 gouverneurs prola on le voit sur sur
ces cartes
je reviens vers vous Armel Anders on
parlera des difficultés de gouverner
pour Lula avec un pays fracturé
évidemment un peu plus tard dans le
débat mais est-ce que bolsonaro a le
pouvoir sur ses gouverneurs est-ce que
c'est leur chef ou est-ce que c'est plus
compliqué que ça parce que si on parle
d'un état confédéré il y a peut-être de
l'autonomie dans État par État oui alors
réponds tout de suite à votre question
il faudra revenir sur quelque chose qui
a été dit avant oui les gouverneurs ils
sont ils peuvent être proches de
bolsonaro avoir été mais ils seront
totalement enfin ils sont pas bolsonro
n'est pas leur chef peut-être pour
certains une idéologie mais je crois pas
et tous les gouverneurs ont besoin de
s'entendre avec le gouvernement fédéral
il y a quelque chose qui est fort dans
le système politique brésilien c'est le
pouvoir exécutif il a quand même la main
sur un certain nombre de il a il a des
leviers sur les états par les agences
fédérales par par la politique fédérale
donc un gouverneur peut difficilement se
permettre d'être vraiment en désaccord
avec la avec la politique fédérale alors
ce qui est important c'est que le
pouvoir final donne effectivement un
accès aux machines électorales et c'est
plutôt sur les élections suivantes où on
verra l'impact de ces de ces
bolsonaristes mais par exemple à s'en
parle qui a toujours été un état
gouverné par la droite ça c'est là c'est
simplement la droite n'existe plus au
Brésil c'est devenu l'extrême droite et
je qualifierai pas bolsonaro de
populiste démagogues si vous voulez mais
populiste non il y a rien de populisme
chez lui c'est de l'extrême droite
pure dur et pas il y a pas de
préoccupation pour le peuple ou de
volonté de protéger ce qui est quand
même une des aspects du populisme entre
lui et les élites parce que lui se dit
hors système et se dit proche du peuple
et il y a aussi tout le corpus de des
informations rhétorique oui
est-ce que voilà on peut en discuter
mais je crois que ça ça permet pas de
vraiment comprendre son projet
donc les gouverneurs le gouverneur de
saint Paul je disais bolsonaris là est
vraiment en plus c'est une initiative de
bolsonaro d'avoir lancé cette
candidature en plus de quelqu'un qui
vient de Rio de Janeiro donc et le
gouverneur à s'en parle c'est un relatif
exploit et
qui est considéré comme un ça a été un
des premiers à dire qu'il travaillerait
avec le gouvernement fédéral et Lula il
est considéré comme un bolsonariste
pragmatique et donc je pense que ça sera
le cas pour beaucoup des défenses
politiques alors Lula il a rapidement
reçu l'efficitations de plusieurs chefs
d'État
occidentaux Joe Biden évidemment le
nouveau Premier ministre britannique
richissounac le Premier ministre
espagnol socialiste Pedro Sanchez et le
président français dans une séquence
filmée évidemment partagée sur les
médias sociaux regardez
bonjour monsieur
le fond
C ouais
[Musique]
je dois te dire que
j'attendais avec beaucoup d'impatience
ce moment pour qu'on puisse relancer un
partenariat stratégique à la hauteur de
notre histoire et des défis qui sont
devant nous merci à toi et félicitations
pour cette élections c'est pour nous une
formidable nouvelle
Gaspard Estrada on va pas analyser la
communication d'Emmanuel Macron oui il y
a des choses à dire il y a des choses à
dire mais moi je voudrais plutôt que
vous entendre sur cette rapidité alors
c'est pas la première fois ça arrive
souvent mais des chefs d'État étrangers
notamment occidentaux à félicité ou là
est-ce qu'il y a quand même une volonté
d'asseoir ça crédibilité la voilà le de
dire la victoire et les Nets elle est
précise bravo à vous et il y a pas de
discussion est-ce que vous l'avez
l'analysez pardon comme ça c'est évident
moi je crois c'est très clair il y a eu
une volonté politique des grandes
capitales notamment
occidentales pour asseoir l'autorité et
surtout le résultat le résultat en
faveur de Lola compte tenu des menaces
qui a pu être évoqué du précédent
américain et donc de ce point de vue là
si vous regardez la chronologie du
dimanche soir le tribunal électoral a
officialisé la victoire de Lola aux
alentours de min heure de Paris le tweet
de d'Emmanuel Macron a été publié à
minuit une ou deux ou trois et si vous
regardez ce qui s'est passé au Canada
aux États-Unis il y a eu véritablement
et ça d'ailleurs la presse brésilienne a
fait état de cette concertation qui a
été menée en amont du scrutin juste pour
éviter tout dérapage institutionnels de
la part de wolsonaro Armelle charrier
même si bon je sais pas s'il faut
employer le terme de populisme et mettre
le Brésil dans le même sac que
d'autres pays les États-Unis ou des pays
d'Europe qui sont confrontés moi ce que
je remarque est-ce que je vois là avec
ce qui se passe au Brésil c'est que
le populisme ou l'extrême droite gagne
ou s'installe dans l'alternance c'est un
peu ça l'histoire de de l'époque est-ce
que vous le ressentez comme ça vous
aussi oui mais c'est pas que l'affaire
du Brésil dans cette région
oui oui et c'est vrai que je
réfléchissais sur les la terminologie
employée d'ailleurs parce que on voit
que il y a toujours cette notion quand
même qui a un moment donné qui va être
de jouer sur du sentiment de jouer sur
la victimisation de jouer sur le fait
qu'on est passé à quelque chose et c'est
ce qu'on a vu avec Donald Trump c'est ce
qu'on voit lui avec avec bolsonaro c'est
peut-être là-dessus aussi qui avait joué
à un moment donné un Boris Johnson quand
il voulait jouer la carte du brexit etc
qui a finalement donné l'impression
qu'il va y avoir une unité qui va se
faire en dehors du jeu institutionnel
d'avoir un type de population qui va se
dire nous on a un champion on a des
idéaux on voit on a une vision
effectivement de ce qui peut se mettre
en place et derrière on en a été frustré
et donc que derrière du coup on va
courir vers quelqu'un qui même s'il
n'est pas là même s'il n'est pas
président même s'il va être on va se
dire ah bah on va attendre c'était cet
épisode c'est peut-être ça effectivement
la comparaison qu'on peut faire ce qui
est marquant en plus c'est que on a
aussi des pays qui ont différents types
de fractures c'est à dire que on a une
fracture qui est une fracture à la fois
économique
bijoux qu'on a vu jouer au Brésil qu'on
a vu évidemment jouer aux États-Unis
qu'on a vu jouer au Royaume-Uni avec le
brexit qu'on a vu jouer aussi en Italie
on a une fracture qui est aussi une
fracture de société qui à la fois à la
fois une société qui est soit urbaine
soit une société qui rurale avec
justement ce clivage que l'on commence
parfois arriver aussi en France on le
voit aussi dans un certain type de de
vote de ressentiment et de perception de
la façon dont vous gérez votre panier de
course votre vie avec le carburant ou
pas de carburant selon que vous soyez en
ville ou à la ou à la ou à la campagne
et puis il y a aussi la question
évidemment d'avoir un avenir alors du
coup les Italiens jouent effectivement
sur aussi à la question de la de
l'immigration et sur la capacité à un
moment donné à dire voilà si vous voulez
qu'on vive avec une unité si on vous
voulez qu'on vit avec des valeurs qui
sont les valeurs chrétiennes qui sont
les valeurs
identitaires dans ces cas-là il faut
qu'on se referme donc en fait on a
toujours des saupoudrages qui sont très
différents mais on voit qu'on est dans
une époque où il y a cette j'allais dire
cette fracture dans les pays et
qu'on ne voit pas comment est-ce qu'on
peut les réunir c'est ça qui me trappe
moi c'est que quand on parle des
États-Unis quand on a l'impression de
parler du Brésil quand on parle de
certains autres pays même par exemple le
Royaume-Uni qui s'est réuni juste pour
la reine mais qui reste dans une
création économique extrêmement
importante c'est cette bipolarisation
aujourd'hui mais c'est pas uniquement
économique moi il me semble aussi que
c'est une cassure entre des croyances en
fait on a deux communautés de croyances
aujourd'hui et un peu ce que Emmanuel
Macron a voulu jouer pendant l'élection
présidentielle le monde de la raison
versus le monde de l'irrationalité
qu'incarnait d'ailleurs bolsonaro
peut-être pas populiste à votre à vos
yeux mais c'était vraiment c'était
surréaliste la façon dont il a mené sa
politique pendant la pendant le covid
etc donc il y a deux mondes maintenant
qui ce qui s'affrontent et qui ne se
parle pas du tout de la même façon avec
pas le même le même mot et ni la même
grammaire c'est ce qui est difficile
Gaspard Estrada est-ce que parce que
c'est ce qui est vocaliste ici on a
parlé de de du destin ou de l'avenir
judiciaire de bolsonaro personne ici
peut dire qui va se passer mais est-ce
que le bolsonarisme
survivra où est en train de survivre à
son chef vous voyez ce que je veux dire
oui bon je pense que ce qu'il faut avoir
à l'esprit c'est que il est clair que il
y a eu un pour le coin un grand
remplacement entre la droite
républicaine et l'extrême droite
aujourd'hui l'extrême droite est devenu
la force motrice de ce camp politique et
ça c'est une réalité le PSDB qui était
donc le parti depuis les années 80 qui
avait incarné le centre droit au Brésil
est une force tout à fait périphérique
qui d'ailleurs dans les fêtes et va
faire partie de la coalition de l'oullah
en tout cas une partie de de ce parti
une autre partie disons publié aux
collectivités locales c'est-à-dire des
maires eux sont des soutiens de
bolsonaro et aujourd'hui c'est l'extrême
droite qui est la force motrice donc de
ce point de vue là oui le bolsonariste
va perturer parce qu'il est en plus il
est implanté dans des dans des états
aussi au Parlement cela étant dit
il faut pas oublier aussi le mode de
fonctionnement en fait des élites
parlementaires au Brésil et le fait que
de manière générale il est il est disons
difficile notamment dans la perspective
des élections locales donc des élections
municipales qui auront lieu dans 2 ans
que les parlementaires s'abstiennent de
faire appel au gouvernement d'où ce que
disait Armel à l'instant au sujet des
gouverneurs les parlementaires vont eux
aussi chercher à avoir un accès au
gouvernement justement pour pouvoir
procéder à des nominations à obtenir des
amendements donc des financements de la
part du gouvernement donc on peut pas
exclure que par exemple des
parlementaires qui ont été élus par le
Parti libéral donc le parti politique
parlementaires sur 513 décide qu'une
partie de ces parlementaires décident de
voter voire face partie de la coalition
de Lula et donc de ce point de vue là il
faut faire très très attention en fait
au rapport de force du l'imaginer vu de
France c'est que c'est comme si Emmanuel
Macron aller chercher sa majorité auprès
du rassemblement national c'est on
essaie de faire une comparaison d'esprit
c'est que Lula lorsqu'il a été au
pouvoir d'ailleurs ça a été le cas de
Cardozo de colore de Cernay et par la
suite de Dilman de tes mères et même de
bolsonaro font de manière générale les
alliances très large lulables de 2003
2010 ça fait l'alliance de la gauche
radicale jusqu'au centre droit alors on
va continuer de de l'expliquer peut-être
en plongeant un peu dans le le système
électoral brésilien mais je vous propose
d'entendre un extrait de du premier
discours de vainqueur de victoire de de
Lula alors justement on parle d'un
Brésil coupé en deux fracturé il
s'adresse à tous les Brésiliens
je suis ici pour gouverner ce pays dans
une situation très difficile mais j'ai
foi en Dieu
et avec l'aide du peuple nous trouverons
une issue pour que ce pays puisse
revivre démocratiquement harmonieusement
nous pouvons même rétablir la paix entre
les familles entre les opinions
divergentes afin de pouvoir construire
le monde dont nous avons besoin et le
brésiles
est-ce qu'il a toujours cette voie là où
est-ce que c'est une voix de fatigue de
fin de campagne électorale cette voix
totalement cassée il a c'est la voix est
cassée par l'accompagne électorale qu'il
a eu il y a quelques années un cancer du
larynx donc la la voie éraillée
faisons un pont de cuit un peu de
cuisine
électoral brésilienne parce
qu'effectivement donc vous nous l'avez
dit le Parti libéral c'est 20% des
sièges le Parti des travailleurs de là
c'est 13% si je ne me trompe donc Lula
c'est toujours l'histoire de de du
pouvoir au Brésil il faut créer une
ambition après les élections parce que
on est dans une proportionnelle
intégrale c'est ça il faut vous n'avez
jamais de majorité net et vous avez une
fragmentation de du système politique
avec une myriade de partie plus ou moins
grande certains ont été des parties
champignons celui le Parti social
libéral qui était le parti de le
huitième partie par lequel bolsonaro est
passé et qu'il a servi à être élu la
première fois qui était parti 3 ou 4
députés et qui s'est retrouvé avec 50
députés et qui voilà alors depuis la
rompue avec ce parti il a été le
candidat à la du Parti libéral donc vous
avez des formations bon comme ça qui a
pas très importante qui ne vivent que de
c'est ce qu'on appelle le physiologisme
au Brésil c'est une espèce d'échange
c'est des formations qui qui se
nourrissent sur la bête
sur le clientélisme
de la de la corruption systémique et
donc les les
l'exécutif n'a pas d'autre solution que
de négocier c'est même pas une coalition
alors il vaut mieux la effectivement
l'affaire là c'est ce qui sur ce sur
quoi ils sont en train de travailler en
ce moment une base ce qu'on appelle au
Brésil mais en fait souvent il faut la
refaire à chaque fois à chaque fois hein
à chaque projet et c'est là c'est
effectivement la la le le problème alors
bolsonaro a fait sa campagne en 2018 en
pour fondant ce système en disant qu'il
ne mangerait pas de ce pain là que ces
formations ce qu'on appelle le sentron
qui n'est pas du tout centriste d'un
point de vue idéologique c'est le marais
le marais mou et et correctile proverbe
de Brasilia le Saint-Trond ne se vend
pas il se loue donc c'est exactement ce
qu'il a commencé à faire parce que les
racines de la corruption voilà non mais
exactement c'est c'est exactement ça et
donc il y a pas il y a pas de 36
solutions il faut il faut négocier donc
accorder contre le vote d'un projet
une nomination à la tête d'une d'une
agence fédérale qui permet ainsi de
nommer des gens enfin c'est vraiment ça
fonctionne ainsi et donc le bolsonaro
qui est quand même passé un moment pas
très loin de la destitution c'est vendu
complètement au centre il s'est mis dans
sa main donc la le poste le plus
important de la République après celui
de président c'est président de l'achat
de la de la Chambre des députés
brésiliens parce que c'est le président
de la Chambre des députés qui qui
revient la prérogative de lancer ou non
les procédures de destitution donc celui
de celui qui avait finalement qui a fait
affaire à retour lire avec bolsonaro
et bien là empêcher a mis les 150
demandes de procédure de destitution
dans son tiroir et là il a fait déjà des
offres de services à Loula mais est-ce
que ça veut dire que on ne sait pas
quelle réforme ou là va engager parce
que moi ça leur parle pardon mais ce que
j'entends là c'est que ça sa majorité
elle va être totalement à géométrie
variable qui va falloir la construire
projet par projet est-ce qu'on sait pas
quelle réforme il va l'engagé dans son
discours de départ il était sur les
questions de pauvreté hein
en disant il y a 33 millions maintenant
de Brésiliens qui meurt de faim et puis
il y en a une 100 millions qui sont avec
des difficultés donc c'est vraiment
cette capacité de dire on va revenir à
ce que j'avais laissé à la fin de mon
deuxième mandat donc ça c'est
indiscutable que ça va être quand même
ce qu'il a porté et ce qui quelque part
négocier avec les uns et des autres moi
ce qui m'a frappé effectivement derrière
c'est la question ensuite de l'écologie
la question de la déforestation de
l'Amazonie qu'il a aussi peut apporter
des voix qu'il a aussi peut apporter des
cohérences en disant il faut quand même
s'appeler à ce problème là il l'avait
beaucoup travaillé je crois dans son
deuxième mandat moins dans son premier
et ça fait partie des questions qui sont
fondamentales aussi pour les parce que
la question de l'Amazonie c'est quand
même une question qui est une question
identitaire donc c'est aussi après
derrière la question de la corruption
parce que lorsque vous faites de la
déforestation c'est pas juste la
déforestation c'est derrière vous avez
de l'élevage intensif vous avez aussi de
l'industrie c'est quels sont les
capacités que vous avez les capacités
minières que vous mettez en place tout
ça et c'est vrai que ces questions elles
sont celles qui sont ressortent le plus
mais comme on va voir dans de nombreux
pays c'est-à-dire que cette question de
la corruption fondamentalement elle est
valable dans plein de pays en fait quand
on voit aujourd'hui il y a la façon dont
les choses se délitent c'est
fondamentalement cette capacité à un
moment donné à se dire on prend le
pouvoir et à un moment donné on
s'enrichit où on partage avec un certain
clan alors l'Amazonie justement je vous
propose d'entendre la réaction de
l'hémisphère spécial des États-Unis pour
le climat John Kerry il dit s'attendre à
des gestes forts de la part du président
élu on était évidemment à quelques jours
de l'ouverture de la COP 27 en Égypte
John Kerry
le président élu Lula est engagé il a
déjà montré cet engagement auparavant
avec un programme qu'il avait mis en
place maintenant j'espère que nous
pourrons affiner ce programme et avancer
encore plus rapidement sur les réformes
nécessaires pour tenter de sauver
l'Amazonie
il y a environ 25 millions de personnes
qui vivent ils n'ont pas beaucoup de
ressources autre que le bétail ou
l'exploitation forestière et nous dans
le reste du monde allons devoir
reconnaître si nous tenons à cette
grande forêt nous devons les aider à la
préserver
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que le
Brésil peut pas sauver son Amazonie
toute seule gaspardestrada invisiblement
c'est l'opinion de John Kerry un soleil
tandis il est clair que la coopération
internationale au-dessus de l'Amazonie
et une question centrale pour le
président élu Lula dans une tribune au
Monde qui a été publiée il y a quelques
jours et le président a fait à
mentionner le fait qu'il y a un fond
amazonique a été créé par la Norvège et
l'Allemagne pour aider à financer en
fait des programmes de défense des de
lutte contre la déforestation se font a
été bloqués en 2019 suite aux actions du
menées par le gouvernement de de
bolsonaro et là très clairement ces deux
gouvernements ont émis leur souhait de
d'abonder de nouveau se font justement
pour augmenter cette coopération
internationale et et faire en sorte que
que l'Amazonie se préservé un mot
là-dessus sur l'Amazonie le gouverneur
de cette
de cette région il est bolsonaristes où
il est où il est Loula
était en tête de justesse en Amazonie il
a gagné l'État mais il a perdu Manaos
enfin il a perdu il a il a Manaus c'est
vraiment des bolsonaristes alors que
Manaus a été les pistes enfin le cas le
plus le plus terrible le plus tragique
de la de la pandémie et de
l'incompétence du gouvernement fédéral
je vous pose cette question à savoir à
quel point la politique amazonienne de
Lula peut être freiné alors vous nous
avez en partie répondu tout à l'heure
par par les Pouvoirs locaux ou par les
lobbylos
c'est sûr c'est le grand problème alors
l'Amazonie c'est une question c'est pas
identitaire enfin les Brésiliens du Sud
c'est très loin l'Amazonie c'est mais
c'est la souveraineté c'est à dire et
Lula était très très clair dans son
discours de son premier discours après
son élection qu'il a lu ce qui est rare
il a improvise ça veut dire qu'il y
avait vraiment il y avait vraiment
préparé et il a bien dit il a rappelé
l'importance de la coopération qui
l'ouvrait à la coopération
internationale mais il a bien martelé
dont la dans le respect de la
souveraineté du Brésil et les propos
d'Emmanuel Macron il y a lors de la
crise disant qu'il fallait que si le
Brésil ne s'occupait pas de de enfin
qu'il fallait internationaliser la
question amazonienne ça a été une erreur
psychologique très très forte vis-à-vis
des Brésiliens allez on va terminer par
une question qui nous concerne également
c'est son les spéculations et je propose
à Mathias ça reste de nous rejoindre
bonsoir Mathias spéculation sur l'avenir
de cet accord entre l'Union européenne
et le Mercosur alors il faut peut-être
déjà rappeler de quoi il s'agit et bien
l'accord
uomerco soir est un projet de
libre-échange entre les pays de l'Union
européenne et les quatre pays membres du
Mercosur à savoir l'Argentine le
Paraguay l'Uruguay et le Brésil donc on
peut le comparer par exemple au CETA qui
nous lie avec le Canada Laurine finit
que prévoit cet accord et bien
l'abaissement des carrière douanière
dans plusieurs domaines dans le sens
Union européenne Marco sourd sur les
voitures les produits pharmaceutiques
chimiques cosmétiques entre autres et
puis dans le sens inverse ce sont des
matières premières qui sont
principalement ciblées à savoir la
viande bovine de volailles des produits
agricoles tels que le soja le miel
l'huile le riz est bien d’autre mais
toujours il faut le souligner cadrer par
des quotas annuels alors pour qualifier
cet accord on peut parler de serpent de
mer absolument et puisque l'ouverture
des négociations et bien elle date de
1999 et plus de 20 ans plus tard
toujours rien alors dire que cet accord
a connu des hauts et des bas et bien
c'est un euphémisme les négociations
même été suspendues à plusieurs reprises
entre 2004 et 2010 alors que Lola était
président d'ailleurs puis entre 2010 et
2012 un va et vient incessant jusqu'à
2018 et une volonté affirmée de la part
de l'Union européenne de trouver un
accord définitif ce qui est arrivé en
juin 2019 pour autant face au manque
d'engagement du président Jaïr bolsonaro
en faveur de l'environnement la c'est
plus particulièrement Emmanuel Macron
ont appuyé des deux pièces sur le frein
dès le mois d'août de la même année ils
ont ensuite été rejoints par l'Allemagne
et d'autres pays résultat plus de 20 ans
après l'ouverture des portes parler
l'accord n'est toujours pas réactif que
peut changer le retour de Lula à la
présidence et ben c'est bien là la
question certains ils voient
l'opportunité côté Union européenne de
relancer les discussions le président
brésilien élu a en effet tendu la main
et dit lors de sa campagne qu'il
espérait parvenir à un accord dans les
six mois un message qui n'est pas tombé
dans l'oreille d'un sourd mais qui
appelle à la prudence comme nous l'a
expliqué la sénatrice les républicains
Marta de Sidrac
la nature ayant horreur du vide je pense
que oui je pense que nous l'attendons et
pourquoi je vous dis la nature a hors du
vide parce que on sait bien qu'il y a
d'autres influences donc d'autres
acteurs économiques qui s'implantent
partout dans le monde et je pense que
l'Union européenne doit en faire partie
doit faire partie de ces acteurs
également présents partout sur notre
planète c'est important c'est important
pour notre continent c'est important
pour l'Union européenne mais restons
aussi très vigilant sur nos valeurs mais
tous n'ont pas entendu la même chose
pour l'économiste Maxime combe
coordinateur du collectif Stop c'est à
merco sourd Lula veut bien discuter mais
dans d'autres termes
la question aujourd'hui qui est posée et
qui est posée par Lula qui est posée par
la société civile brésilienne par la
société civile d'Amérique du Sud qui est
également très largement défavorable à
la profondissement de la mondialisation
telle qu'elle existe et de l'enjeu c'est
plutôt effectivement de prendre au mot
Lula il dit qu'il souhaite aller en ce
sens-là et bien pour cela ça nécessite
de réouvrir la négociation sur le
contenu de l'accord qui nous convient
pas et donc du coup faisons cela prenons
le temps de redéfinir qu'elles peuvent
être des partenariats entre les pays du
Mercosur et les pays de l'Union
européenne qui soit à la hauteur des
défis du 21e siècle et bien la passation
de pouvoir est prévue le 1er janvier
prochain à faire à suivre donc merci
Mathias Armel charrier est-ce que le on
parlait de la pour nous parler de la
pauvreté enfin c'est dans le bilan du du
mandat de bolsonaro c'est que c'est
quand même une des pires catastrophes
est-ce que le Brésil a besoin de cet
accord avec l'Europe pour redonner du
souffle à son économie ça lui donnerait
certes du souffle avec son économie mais
ça lui donnerait aussi des passerelles
en fait maintenant avec aussi des
territoires qui avec lesquels on va
discuter mais maintenant ça il y a eu
tellement de recul avec bolsonaro que il
y a aussi cette volonté de revenir dans
le jeu international la question se pose
sur cette question là elle se pose aussi
par exemple sur la question de la Russie
sur la question de l'Ukraine qui sont
aussi des questions importantes et donc
du coup de savoir comment est-ce que le
Brésil va se positionner c'est quand
même une des grandes économies qui a été
mise effectivement un peu en sommeil on
se rappelle les briques à un moment
donné et ont parié sur le Brésil
tient un mot de la Russie parce que pour
l'instant lu là il est il est de quoi il
est il est pro russe il est il attend de
voir
il je pense que il voudra reprendre son
rôle à la fin de ses mandats il essaie
de jouer un rôle de donner un rôle de
médiateur au Brésil sur le plan
international on se souvient ça avait
été plus ou moins heureux de ces
de ce de ces relations avec Armani
nedjad et les rangs Armani Legend et
sans doute il pense que le Brésil doit
avoir un rôle de médiateur dans cette
dans cette crise et que pour avoir un
rôle de médiateur il faut être neutre ou
à peu près et puis pour des raisons
économiques il y a des la Russie est
importante ne serait-ce que pour le
lobby enfin pour le pour la gros
l'agriculture brésilienne donc
ça va être un mélange de pragmatisme et
de volonté de faire du Brésil un acteur
majeur des relations internationales
gaspardestrada sur sur la on reste sur
l'économie la lutte contre la la
pauvreté il faut quand même dire un mot
de l'histoire personnelle du destin de
de Lula quoi c'est quand même que c'est
ce que je me disais ce matin après prend
l'émission quel destin quel destin est
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ces dernières
années parce que un Lula est en effet
parcours je dirais unique par rapport
aux grands dirigeants internationaux
c'est un métall qui a perdu un doigt en
travaillant dans une usine qui a migrant
parce qu'il était donné dans le nord-est
il est parti avec une famille c'était 8
ou 9 frères famille très pauvre famille
extrêmement pauvre il a commencé à
travailler à 12 13 ans il a fondé un
syndicat il allait en prison elle sous
la dictature militaire il a créé un
parti politique il a perdu aussi sur le
plan personnel il l'a perdu sa première
femme et son premier enfant lorsqu'il
était ouvrier dans un hôpital dans une
petite clinique sa deuxième femme est
morte d'un AVC en 2017 lorsqu'il y a eu
toute cette opération anticorruption et
qu'il avait été mis en examen il a été
aussi donc incarcéré il est revenu
éligible en 2021 et là il revient à la
présidence de la République après avoir
eu deux mandat il avait fini son
deuxième mandat en 2010 avec un taux de
popularité de 87% Obama qui venait
d'être élu en 2009 avec guide de Lula
qui était l'homme critique le plus
populaire du monde faut que je pense que
il y a peu d'hommes politiques en tout
cas de notre vie dans notre époque qui
peuvent avoir un tel parcours Laetitia
très naïve toute simple est-ce que c'est
fréquent qu'un président comme ça ancien
reviennent et soit réélu après plusieurs
plusieurs années j'ai pas l'impression
au Brésil c'est la première du monde
alors ça je vais on va ça c'est une
question compliquée parce qu'on va pas
forcément avoir la réponse tout de suite
il va falloir qu'on fasse mouliner les
cerveaux mais on va pas avoir la réponse
il y en a un c'est j'ai tout lu au
vargasme qui avait qui était arrivé à
une époque de la dictature militaire et
qui est par la suite a été élu et il
finit s'est suicidé donc c'est pas un
très bon nez voilà
mais c'est comme ça merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce débat melender je
rappelle que votre histoire du Brésil
est publié aux éditions chandaignes
voilà merci encore pour ce premier débat